you have a a thing in your your
household like cooking paa is like a
very dangerous thing what and why what
yeah what happened I think this is fake
news people this is something is going
around no I hear it's about fire okay
okay all right I am a that check that
that I'm a cook that I believe my
daughters to be out of Danger's way I
will have them better prepared for life
life if I teach them from early on about
the dangers of the world not putting
them behind walls so yes I let my
daughters use knives with barely they
were two years old and cook with open
fire and sometimes the fires I make at
home they can be very big cooking the
paa and my and the fire is bigger than
my
daughter's and the fire is a really big
fire and when you have little daughters
and big fire and you teaching your
daughters how to make the paa the fire
sometimes is nice the the fire wants to
help you wants to kiss you because fire
is a good person if you treat it with
respect and I think the fire B used to
give kind of a little kiss to my
daughter's
eyebrows and and was a little you know
smelly little bit my daughters were over
doing a daddy you Barn me I didn't Barn
you who's the fire who's the fire I said
don't tell anything to Mommy please
don't just let's keep it I mean yeah
when I forgot one of my daughters yeah
in the supermarket but I came back I hey
but I came back
hey I I I didn't had salt and was very
important I was making a fishing salt
and my daughter yeah you got the salt
but what about me so yeah but the fire
and that I I don't think fire in the
year yeah yeah
fire oh my gosh that looked cool too the
thing you were cooking it in that was
really cool we showed the video of that
big black thing that was cool AA pen
that is what no but what's the thing
underneath of it was it connected yeah
it's like is look I'm going to be real
with you I make like nothing so like I'm
not a cook so I've never seen yeah yeah
no you're not a cook no and I am it's
not fair you you don't sing when you
cook no yeah that's I got the one man
yeah that's it still I don't think she
has one t I think she has many many T I
can't even make eggs all
right people of America the Kelly and
Jose cooking show she teach me I'm she
teaches me to sing and I teach her to
cook b as long as no one okay I'll do
[Music]
that
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home